Good morning. I'm coming at you from my extremely clean bedroom
basically. Long story short,
yesterday
I kinda lost the plot and ended up organising my entire bedroom
and all of my clothes and even painting my wardrobe
which wasn't on my bingo card for yesterday or Eva really. Anyway,
so it's been about a month since I got my hair done.
I think we went for a gloss and a tone and we went darker
but it has faded heaps
so we're going back in and I don't know what I'm gonna get done today
but hopefully whatever it is it's giving so let's go.
So this is our before and excuse me for not putting any makeup on,
I just didn't have time today
the brief is dimension cause at the moment it's looking a little flat
so we're gonna do some brightness,
some belly arch and hopefully
I'll come out of here looking and feeling like a new woman
are you even a girl
unless you've got three beverages on the girl at once?
Hey, it feels a bit more like me.
I just realised I failed to finish that vlog off properly
and I'm sorry about it
so here I am looking like an absolute fucking mess
a couple of days later because I am balls deep
and another project with a tight deep line
and please don't ask me, okay,
why these happen because I don't know.
Here's the hair few days later
I'm enjoying The lightness,
enjoying the brightness. I feel like now when I look in the mirror,
I just see what I think I look like.
But when it was darker, I was always like, whoa,
who the fuck's that? Do you know what I mean?
Feel free to let me know what you like better,
the night or the dark. In the meantime,
have a beautiful Easter, eat lots of Chuckies guilt free,
spend time with your family
and I will see you with a project update as soon as I possibly can.